we're back with stephen king someone i
have known my whole life
and love so dearly as we all do because
you've
changed the course of all of our lives
you have painted in the minds of all of
us
the greatest stories scenarios
characters
worlds and i'd love to talk to you about
some of all of our favorites
in something we're calling on the books
oh this is going to be like a roshack
test
okay carrie published in 1974 a movie
released in 1976.
what are your thoughts well what i
remember is that when the movie rights
were sold for 6 500 i ran out to
mcdonald's and bought my wife and i
uh orange blizzard shakes okay that is
beyond my
expectations or dreams for what this is
that's exactly it okay
the shining published in 1977 movie
released in 1980
well i didn't really like the movie that
much but i did like the little boy that
played
uh danny torrance and uh of course
since then here's johnny has become
associated with my name forever and why
did you not
love the movie not to press if you don't
want to tell me it's fine but i'm
curious
no the book was warm and the movie was
cold it was a kubrick film
and don't get me wrong i love everything
else the man did
i just didn't like that one the greatest
thing about it
is if you're not involved if it's really
good you can say that's based on my book
if it's really bad you can say i didn't
have anything to do with it
okay fire starter published in 1980
movie released in 1984 shot in 82.
i thought that you were terrific in that
part that was
very very difficult and you were great
what every time that you got really
ready to light a
fire your beautiful blonde hair would
blow back it was great
that's it yeah that's the word i loved
getting to play
charlie mcgee more than words can ever
express and when you're seven and you
think you can blow people away
with a fireball it's really empowering
yeah okay so from different seasons in
1982 came stand by me
the movie in 1986. what i remember
about writing that was my wife and i
were living
in an old house that was too small for a
writing room
and so there was a barn next door and i
used to
work on stand by me which was then
called the body
in my underwear because it was summer
and it was so hot in there but the
memories just came flooding back
oh i love that detail that's right the
body of course
oh i love that okay
one of my personal favorites they're all
my favorites christine
published in 1983 movie released in
1983.
that's a quick turnover i had a plymouth
like that uh it wasn't quite that year
but uh it was rattling and it was
breaking down and
one day when i was driving home i
thought to myself you know what would be
really
great is if the odometer on this thing
started to run backwards
and every time it turned past like a
fender bender or a flat tire
that thing would fix itself and i
thought you know that's a great story i
think i want to write that it'll be
really funny but it didn't turn out to
be that
that funny after all i love that it's
brilliant okay another
book you wrote that also became such an
incredible movie
misery published a 1987 movie in 1990
at that time you know i i went to
autographings and
people would line up and they would all
say the same thing i'm your number one
fan and i thought i thought to myself
you can't all be my number one fan
somewhere there
must be a number two fan or a number
three
but uh they would bring things and and
some of them were
very very serious about uh
various parts of the stories and
everything and i thought
you know i would hate to be captured by
one of these and have to write a book
and then the thing just followed
after i mean it was just perfect
it was just it was like automatic
writing almost
ah and a detail about your new novel
later
i had an idea for a story about a
uh a literary agent a woman who was on
her own
and she had financial problems and she
had
one big client that was supposed to pay
all the bills because
her life was just falling apart and the
guy drops dead
so what are you going to do about that
and i held on to that idea for quite a
while
and then i thought what if she had a kid
who could talk to dead people
and they had to tell him the truth and i
thought that little boy
could tell her the whole story and she
could write it under his name
so i started with that and i just
i had such a good time with that book
and i hope people who read it have a
good time it's it's
uh sort of light and tasty but i think
it's also scary so
i just love being in your world for
years and i'm
so happy to reconnect with you
well right back at you i love being with
you and
getting a chance to connect with you and
and see your happy
face and i'm i just hope everything's
going great for you
and i watched the show and i read your
book and you were in firestarter and
you're in cat's eye
and we have a real connection it's great
we really do
just don't lock me up in a room and make
me write a book well i am your number
one fan
oh i love you stephen king thank you so
much for coming here please
if you'll come on your next project i
would be so honored
later is available now it dropped
it's here and we will it's here it's
[Music]
here
you